[Music]
preseason is obviously one of the most
important times for a professional
footballer well it's fair to say that
it's not a one-size-fits-all approach
isn't it preseason is critical for the
players in preparing them physically and
mentally and tactically for the the
scenes ahead
it's our main opportunity for double
sessions it is just about fueling and
recovering quickly for those sessions to
make sure that the guys can go and go
again Carbon say it could vary
significantly impressive different goals
players do the double training days who
were just trying to get through and fuel
those sessions but then you've got a
couple of boys that were quite low carb
intake at times where they're trying to
do some body fat and then we've got the
young players they're coming through it
we're still trying to grow and develop
so we're actually increasing their
intake you're on again it's quite high
carb intakes and a big focus on live
quality proteins as well the days of
running man the pitch you know several
times and not seen a ball for the first
few weeks of faeces and they're long
gone and a lot of our preseason is to
incorporate a lot of the conditioning
practices with the ball the nutritional
requirements of pre-season are supported
really well to ensure the players take
onboard the rights the nutritional
requirements and that they can perform
day after day
so obviously nutrition is really
important between finishing the training
session and then just start in a
subsequent session you know we want the
players to take in quality protein to
recover from the training that they've
just done and then also provide an
adaptation for the training that they're
going to do following hard training
sessions will use regal or vehicle
quality carbohydrate and protein source
for the players preseason for us
typically overseas this year it's in LA
in the u.s. it can be quite hot and
humid
so yeah hydrations a big focus of
science in sport product range seems to
be blessed with a decent amount of
electrolytes really whether that's go
electric right through to the recovery
product so we're getting a decent hit of
a broad range of electrolytes in their
pre-season nutritions highly
individualized it's just about training
hard and getting those sort of physical
adaptations it's where all the works
done really
[Music]